.
Hallo, Freunde der Sonne,
ich bin es mal wieder.
Mai, eure Chemikerin des Vertrauens.
Ich habe vor 1,5 Jahren dieses Video
über Fluoride und Zahnpasta gemacht,
und seitdem werde ich
immer wieder nach Ölziehen gefragt.
Beim Ölziehen nimmt man
einen Löffel Kokosöl, Sesamöl
oder irgendein
anderes natürliches Öl,
und zieht sich das ein paar Minuten
lang durch die Zähne,...
* Gurgelgeräusch *
...bevor man es wieder ausspuckt.
Weil das gut für die Zähne
und vieles mehr sein soll.
Ich kannte das es lange nicht,
in meinem Freundeskreis ist Ölziehen
nicht wirklich verbreitet.
Was wahrscheinlich daran liegt,
dass der
aus vielen Chemikern besteht.
Sagt mal, findet ihr es nicht eklig,
dass wir mit unseren Kitteln
Mais Wohnzimmer kontaminieren?
Und Chemiker neigen schnell dazu,
"natürliche" Sachen zu belächeln.
Ha, Öl...
Dabei ist das natürlich genauso
falsch wie die generelle Vorstellung,
dass alles "Natürliche"
viel sanfter ist als Chemie.
Ob irgendwas aus der Natur kommt
oder aus dem Labor,
spielt keine Rolle.
# Denn Darling, alles ist Chemie
Deshalb will ich hier mal
ganz unvoreingenommen rangehen,
und zum Glück gibt es zum Thema
Ölziehen ein paar wissenschaftliche
Studien, die mir da helfen werden.
D.h., ihr wisst, was jetzt kommt -
es wird mal wieder Zeit
für "wissenschaftlich geprüft".
Ich werde mir diese Studien genauer
anschauen und am Ende
Ölziehen scientifically approven,
oder auch nicht.
Los geht's.
* Titelmelodie *
Ölziehen ist eine traditionelle
Praxis aus der ayurvedischen Lehre,
die aus Indien stammt,
inzwischen aber hierzulande
auch ganz beliebt ist, denn das Öl
soll nicht nur Essensreste
und Schmutz aus den Zähnen ziehen,
sondern auch
Bakterien und Giftstoffe.
Es soll nicht nur weißere Zähne
machen und gegen Karies
und Zahnfleischbeschwerden helfen,
sondern noch sehr viel mehr:
das Immunsystem stärken,
den Hormonhaushalt regulieren,
Kopfschmerzen reduzieren,
mehr Energie liefern, und und und.
Letztere Sachen
klingen sehr esoterisch,
aber tatsächlich gibt es
ganz interessante Zusammenhänge
zwischen einem gesunden Mund
und einem gesunden Körper.
Z.B. geht Parodontitis tatsächlich
einher mit einem erhöhten Risiko
für bestimmte Krankheiten,
z.B. Herzerkrankungen,
Diabetes, Alzheimer.
Klingt verwunderlich, doch es gibt
verschiedene mögliche Verknüpfungen.
Z.B. könnte eine Entzündung im Mund,
so wie jede Entzündung im Körper,
das Immunsystem und damit
auch den ganzen Körper belasten.
Oder die Bakterien, die Parodontitis
auslösen, könnten über die Blutbahn
auch in andere Teile
des Körpers gelangen.
Doch die genauen
komplexen Zusammenhänge,
das wäre Stoff für ein eigenes Video.
Zum Einfluss von Ölziehen
auf Dinge wie Immunsystem usw.
gibt es allerdings keine Forschung,
überhaupt keine Forschung.
Deswegen entspringen sämtliche
Claims, die man im Internet findet,
höchstens persönliche Auffassungen.
Deswegen haken wir mal
alle Effekte von Ölziehen,
die über den Mund hinausgehen ab
als not approved,
dazu gibt es derzeit
keine wissenschaftlichen Belege.
Aber: Wie sieht es
mit Zahnhygiene aus?
Ah.... warte. Hi!
Ich kann mir theoretisch vorstellen,
wie Ölziehen funktionieren könnte.
Man kann ja Stoff einteilen
in hydrophil und hydrophob.
Hydrophil heißt wörtlich übersetzt
"wasserliebend",
hydrophob "wasserhassend".
Hydrophil und hydrophob
gehen also nicht so gut zusammen.
Da Öl sehr hydrophob ist,
könnte es Sachen aufnehmen,
die durch Wasser
nicht so leicht entfernt sind.
Das könnten Essensreste sein,
auch Bakterien.
Zahnpasta enthält auch Tenside,
also Moleküle, die sowohl hydrophil
als auch hydrophob sind,
also sich sowohl mit dem Wasser
als auch mit dem Schmutz
gut verstehen.
Dreck, Schmutz, Make-up, Fette, Öle -
also alles, was sich nicht so gut
in Wasser löst.
Das alles wird
in der Zelle eingeschlossen
und mit dem Wasser weggewaschen.
Tenside sind sowieso total cool.
Wer mehr dazu wissen möchte,
und ganz nebenbei noch lernen möchte,
wie man Inhaltsstoffe
auf Kosmetikprodukten richtig liest,
sollte sich
mal dieses Video reinziehen.
Durch das Ziehen, also
durch die physikalische Behandlung,
wird das Öl außerdem emulgiert.
Also es bildet sich eine Emulsion,
eine Mischung aus Öl und Wasser.
Das sieht man auch daran, dass das
Ganze nach einer Zeit milchig wird.
Das Öl wird quasi zerrissen
in viele kleine Öltröpfchen,
so dass es viel mehr
relative Oberfläche gewinnt,
über dass es Sachen aufnehmen könnte.
So viel zur Hypothese, aber
funktioniert das auch in der Praxis?
Tatsächlich gibt es dazu einige
Studien, schauen wir uns zuerst
die Studien zu allgemeiner
Mundhygiene und Gesundheit an.
Am Ende gucken wir noch,
was es mit dieser Zahnaufhellung
auf sich hat.
Jetzt ist Studie nicht gleich Studie.
Verschiedene Studien
haben verschiedene Studien-Designs,
und damit auch
verschieden große Aussagekraft.
Treue Freunde der Sonne wissen, dass
randomisierte, kontrollierte Studien
als Goldstandard gehandelt werden.
Und bei der Forschungsfrage,
ist Ölziehen
gut für Mundhygiene und Gesundheit,
ist es nur sinnvoll,
sich nur randomisierte,
kontrollierte Studien anzuschauen.
Denn nur sie haben bei diesem Thema
ausreichend große Aussagekraft.
Denn größere Beobachtungsstudien o.Ä.
gibt es bei diesem Thema nicht.
Ich habe mal
alle Studien durchforstet.
Ich muss sagen:
Randomisierte, kontrollierte Studien
gibt es leider nicht viele.
Also gut untersucht
ist das Thema bisher noch nicht.
Aber die Studien, die es gibt,
die kommen größtenteils
zu einem ähnlichen Ergebnis,
und das ist ganz interessant.
Aber bevor ich euch das verrate,
müssen wir erst mal verstehen,
was genau
in diesen Studien gemessen wurde.
Denn ein einfaches "Meine Zähne
fühlen sich viel besser an"
ist viel zu unspezifisch.
Man kann z.B.
den "Plaqueindex" bestimmen.
Ihr erinnert euch: Unsere Zähne
sind umgeben von einem Biofilm
namens Plaque. Plaque!
Je niedriger der Plaque-Index,
desto weniger Plaque
und desto besser die Mundhygiene.
Dann gibt es noch
den "Gingivalindex",
der Auskunft gibt über die Gesundheit
des Zahnfleisches,
lateinisch "gingiva".
Außerdem wissen wir von diesem Video,
in der Plaque hausen
viele kleine Mikroorganismen,
die z.B. den Zahnschmelz anknabbern
und Karies verursachen.
Deshalb lohnt es sich auch,
anhand eines Speichelabstrichs
die Anzahl bestimmter Bakterien
zu bestimmen.
Z.B. von "Streptococcus Mutans",
das sind die Haupt-Kariesbakterien.
Und auch Mundgeruch ist ein Faktor
bei Mundhygiene und Gesundheit,
und wird gemessen.
Da gibt es verschiedene Messmethoden.
Entweder subjektiv,
indem wir Versuchsteilnehmer
einen Geruchsjuroren anpusten.
Oder durch selbst beurteilen,
in dem die Teilnehmer
an ihrem Handgelenk lecken
und anschließend
am getrockneten Speichel riechen.
Und dann gibt es zum Glück
auch noch objektive Messmethoden
für den Mundgeruch: auch wieder
durch Bestimmung von Bakterien,
die besonders
für Mundgeruch verantwortlich sind.
Ihr seht: Es gibt tatsächlich mehrere
wissenschaftliche Messmethoden,
um zu bestimmen, wie die Situation
jetzt hier aussieht.
Zurück zu unseren Studien.
Ich habe rund 10 randomisierte,
kontrollierte Studien gefunden,
die aber nicht alle gerade genannten
Messmethoden durchgeführt haben.
Manche haben z.B.
nur den Plaqueindex bestimmt,
andere haben nur die Streptococcus-
Bakterien gemessen usw.
Bei den meisten Studien
wurde das Ölziehen so angewendet:
einmal täglich, vor dem Zähneputzen,
über einen Zeitraum
von einer oder mehreren Wochen.
Als Kontrolle wurde entweder
konventionelles Mundwasser verwendet,
und zwar Mundwasser
mit dem antibakteriellen Wirkstoff
Chlorhexidin,
oder auch nur Wasser.
Da habe ich mich gefragt:
Beim Ölziehen weiß ich es nicht,
das könnt ihr gerne
in die Kommentare schreiben,
wann man das macht, aber Mundwasser
benutzt man
nach dem Zähneputzen, oder?
Oder ist das jetzt so eine große
Debatte, die die Bevölkerung spaltet?
Wie: Wann benutzt man Zahnseide,
vor oder nach dem Zähneputzen?
Ganz klar vor dem Zähneputzen.
Team vorm Zähneputzen!
Die Ergebnisse waren: Das Ölziehen
hatte in den meisten Studien
einen vergleichbaren Effekt
wie das Mundwasser.
D.h. im Vergleich zum Spülen
mit normalem Wasser
ließen sich sowohl mit Ölziehen
als auch mit Mundwasser
verbesserte Mundhygienewerte messen.
Also vom Plaque-Index
über Bakterienanzahl -
alles, was ich gerade erzählt habe,
Mundgeruch usw.
Das mag eine gute Nachricht sein
für alle, die wie ich finden,
dass Mundwasser viel zu brutal ist.
Es gibt ja auch
so softe Mundspülungen,
die man durchaus
länger im Mund haben kann,
aber wonach sich der Mund
nicht wirklich frischer anfühlt.
Oder es gibt
diese brutalen Mundspülungen,
die ich noch nicht mal für ein paar
Sekunden im Mund behalten kann.
Ich verstehe überhaupt nicht,
wie Leute das machen.
Bin ich die einzige, der das so geht?
Brennt das nicht bei euch?
Dafür muss man ja auch nicht super
lang spülen, in den Studien
wurde das Mundwasser
meist für eine Minute angewendet.
Beim Ölziehen
sieht es aber ganz anders aus.
Der Anwendungszeit in den Studien
waren 5-10 Minuten lang.
Ist das normal?
Falls Ölzieher unter euch sind,
schreibt mal in die Kommentare,
wie lange ihr das so macht.
Außerdem fand ich,
ich habe es erst einmal probiert,
dieses Gefühl von reinem Öl
auf der Zunge eher so mittelgeil,
ein bisschen gewöhnungsbedürftig.
Aber die Studien sagen: Ölziehen kann
die Mundhygiene messbar verbessern.
Also approved.
Aber 2 Achtungs.
Achtung Nummer 1: Es gibt bisher
nicht nur wenige Studien,
auch die Teilnehmerzahlen hauen
einen nicht wirklich vom Hocker.
Die meisten Studien
haben 20-40 Teilnehmer,
das ist statistisch
nicht besonders stark.
Deshalb bisher:
Aber nur mit ausdrücklichem Zusatz:
More research needed.
Achtung Nummer 2:
Mundwasser ist nicht nur
keine ausreichende Zahnpflege,
sondern Mundwasser
könnte möglicherweise
sogar zu viel des Guten sein.
In dieser Studie von 2017 wird
z.B. davor gewarnt, dass Mundwasser
das Risiko für Diabetes
erhöhen könnte.
Es wird vermutet, dass Mundwasser
auch die "guten" Bakterien killt,
was dann negativen Einfluss
auf den ganzen Körper haben könnte.
Also da wären wir wieder
bei dieser interessanten Verknüpfung
zwischen Mund und Körper.
Hier ist jetzt auch erst mal
more research needed.
Aber wenn jetzt Ölziehen wirklich
vergleichbar messbare Effekte hat
wie Mundwasser,
dann ist es nicht auszuschließen,
dass es auch vergleichbare
Nebeneffekte haben könnte.
Nur einen klaren Vorteil gibt es wohl
von Ölziehen gegenüber Mundwasser,
denn zumindest Mundwasser
mit Chlorhexidin
kann auch
zu ungewünschten Verfärbungen führen.
Damit kommen wir zu der Frage:
Macht Ölziehen
die Zähne wirklich weißer?
Hier ist die wissenschaftliche Lage
wieder etwas enttäuschend.
Ich habe tatsächlich
nur eine Studie gefunden,
und das ist nur eine In-vitro-Studie.
D.h., man hat hier menschliche Zähne
im Labor untersucht
und mit verschiedenen Dingen
behandelt,
also mit Wasserstoffperoxid,
also einem wirksamen Bleichmittel,
als positive Kontrolle, dann mit
Kokosöl, Sesamöl und Sonnenblumenöl.
Und dann noch als negative Kontrolle
mit einer Salzlösung.
Die Öle schnitten hier
nicht besser ab als die Kontrolle.
Also es gab keine nennenswerte
Aufhellung,
im Gegensatz zum Bleichmittel.
D.h. hier: not approved,
aber auch ganz klar:
more research needed.
Denn man sollte
neben so einer In-vitro-Studie
das Ganze auch mal im großen Maßstab,
In-vivo, also mit Menschen,
untersuchen.
Aber
das wurde bisher noch nicht gemacht.
Auch hier kann ich nur wiederholen:
Schaut meine Zähne an.
Alles, was ihr dafür braucht,
ist ein guter Weißabgleich.
Zumindest sind bisher keine
Nebenwirkungen von Ölziehen bekannt.
Wobei das auch
nicht so verwunderlich ist,
weil das Thema
noch nicht so gut untersucht ist.
Also ich benutze kein Mundwasser,
und werde jetzt
auch nicht mit Ölziehen anfangen.
Schließlich reicht ordentliches
Zähneputzen für einen gesunden Mund.
Mein persönliches Fazit ist:
Mundwasser oder Ölziehen -
kann man machen,
kann man auch lassen.
Was sind eure Erfahrungen
mit Mundwasser oder Ölziehen?
Und v.a.: Was soll ich
als nächstes wissenschaftlich prüfen?
Schreibt es in die Kommentare,
wir sehen uns nächste Woche.
Bis dahin: Bleibt sicher!
Untertitel:
ARD Text im Auftrag von Funk (2019)